alors eric zemmour peut-il être
président c'est vrai qu'on l'a vue là il
a fait un meeting la passe était pas
voir dans un meeting des images de
foules en délire samedi soir à nice où
étaient présents pour la promo de son
livre on a l'impression que c'est un
meeting politique vous avez vu les
images regardez c'est un truc de ouf a
abaissé ses basses et booba au stade de
france c'est un show qui voient là
le rendez vous était censé être une
rencontre littéraire mais les images
parlent d'elles-mêmes à nice hier il
s'agissait bien d'un meeting
[Musique]
mais moi je ne suis pas un politique
madame je ne suis pas un chef de parti
qui a besoin d'argent public pourtant
dès avril dernier son mouvement était
lancé
les amis d'eric zemmour des
recommandations appliquées à la lettre
eric zemmour a désormais tout d'un
politique les gestes et le discours
l'essayiste a déjà démarché des élus
pour obtenir les 500 parrainages passage
obligé pour se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle
ouais alors tu as bien joué j'ai vu que
tu avais rêvé c'est vrai qu'on a c'est
vrai qu'on a fondu
c'est touche pas à mon poste t'inquiète
pas au collet du président alors tu
pense qu'il peut être président il
exhume genre jamais je sais qu'en juin
dernier et à signer une pétition pour
qu'il soit complètement bannis des
médias
moi je relis un truc ouattara oui mais
bon ouais ouais entre antoine tu pense
qu'il peut être président eric zemmour
ben moi je pense ouais ouais j'ai une
petite anecdote je me suis garé devant
tout à l'heure il ya un monsieur qui
m'interpelle et qui me dit vous êtes le
porte parole des amis d'éric de mots et
on discute de minutes je demande le
prénom ce monsieur il s'appellera chine
il a entre 40 et 50 ans et il m'explique
ben moi j'ai eu une jeunesse délinquante
mais aujourd'hui je suis père de famille
je suis pas d'accord avec tout ce qu'il
dit mais indéniablement il faut que ça
se calme dans un rachid si ç'avait été
révélé leur disant vous appelez didier
et est donc et donc il me dit bah moi
maintenant je suis père de famille je
souhaite que ça se calme pour mes
enfants et c est qu on puisse vivre
tranquillement partout et donc moi je
crois que booba et père de famille aussi
et donc moi ce que j'ai envie de me dire
c'est que je comprends bien qu'il ya
dans le rap des paroles hyper forte etc
ça peut être vue de manière artistique
mais une fois qu'on a passé la
quarantaine qu'on a des enfants est ce
qu'on change pas un peu et qu'on se dise
finalement il faudrait qu'on puisse
vivre tranquillement partout en france
que les policiers les pompiers puissent
aller dans tous les quartiers parce
qu'un enfant une mère de famille peut en
avoir besoin
alors bon ben je fais pas de politique
je veux dire pas déjà président des amis
d'eric zemmour en fait il y a
aujourd'hui c'est à son enfance il ya
partout en france des gens qui espèrent
qu'ils récusent amour soit candidat et
donc à la base c'est une page facebook
les amis d'eric zemmour on s'est
organisé en association et on est
rejoint par de très nombreuses
françaises est très nombreux français
moi je préfère ce sont les amis de boer
a les amis de booba je pouvais être
pourtant
il ya des caméras de tf a confirmé une
scène assez particulière ce week-end on
entend et déguisés moore parlait que son
conseiller en communication quelques
minutes avant de monter sur scène et là
on est clairement dans le coaching d'un
homme politique regardez son conseiller
en communication le met en garde sur sa
gestuelle et les changeant dit non
et non donner la vie
alors bon il va se présenter c'est sûr
alors aujourd'hui eric zemmour il dit
lisez moi peut-être que demain il dira
élisez moi mais pour l'instant c'est le
temps de l'écrire
non je pense que c'est un pétard on
achète son lieu exactement ma jeunesse
qui veut vendre un livre et puis
éventuellement vous vous êtes derrière
lui vous voulez absolument qui se
présente on espère mais le privé d'abord
il a pas les 500 signatures et je pense
que c'est pas fait mais s'il n'a pas de
parti donc ça veut dire quoi on va élire
les égouts en ont ras-le-bol des
partenaires mais ce qu'il y aura des
élections de mai sauf que
lors des élections législatives après
donc on va en fait il va gouverner avec
thierry zemour avec vous vous lui
souhaitez du bonheur vous souhaiter
qu'il soit dévoyée de majorité
parlementaire tout juste d'un bouquin il
veut biaiser montre un bouquin
allègement sassafras pilote pour cent
mais rien de plus il l'a dit et les
croisements programme eric zemmour x et
le plein de haine je sais quoi son
programme de dons un programme plein de
haine non franchement mais s'est
concentrée sur un jour
n'est pas encore candidat mais il s'est
déjà exprimé sur un certain nombre de
choses à dire quoi les prénoms et c'est
fait qu'elle soit la ferme en regarder
aujourd'hui vous rétablir y est la peine
de mort ou pas
je peux juste non non je n'hésite pas je
ne suis pas au pouvoir en plus c'est
très compliqué je mets abolir la peine
de mort je ne pense pas que on est bien
fait d'abolir la peine de mort
maintenant la peine de mort
philosophiquement oui vous savez une
majorité de français est favorable à la
peine de mort encore aujourd'hui je
pense d'ailleurs que vous savez quand on
va exécuter les terroristes du bataclan
en syrie soir 2-2 de françois hollande
on a rétabli la peine de mort donc on le
veut on le fait sans le dire
je trouve ça dommage si les hémorroïdes
a réussi l'exploit de se hisser comme
potentiel candidat crédible à la
présidentielle et là il se tire une
balle dans pays se décrédibilise avec
des mesures qui sont irréalisables qui
n'ont pas de sens interdire le prénom
mohamed interdire la peine de mort c'est
extrêmement clients et je pense que ça
le décrédibilise plus qu'autre chose
mais il ya plein de gens qui le découvre
en tant que candidat même si les deux
premières mesures qu'on entend interdire
mohamed et
son livre
histoire de prénom j'avais dit vouloir
interdire les prénoms étrangers se sont
illustrés dans étrangers ou seulement
les prénoms musulmans que vous voulez à
l'étranger pas seulement musulman je
pense si vous voulez que vous savez
c'est une loi qui a été établie en 1803
un enfant qui s'appelle mohamed moi je
trouve que au bout de trois générations
ça c'est la troisième génération je
trouve ça triste il s'appelle encore moi
mais vous savez pourquoi les lélés les
immigrés arabo musulman ne donne pas de
prénom français parce que ce sont des
prénoms chrétiens qu'ils ne veulent pas
ils veulent persévérer dans leur être
islam manche et je les appelle moi mais
j'arrête le débat donc sur la toile avec
heaven merci en tout 40 ans et court
mais intense merci
[Applaudissements]